uh-oh before this video began it's time
for me to flex on your kids I got a
brand-new origin PC computer I have no
idea what's inside it but based on the
gamer lights instead I could tell it's
pretty damn powerful I thought that look
at this how it is not the greatest
computer ever made with this I can
finally destroy t-series but this is not
just it you guys can win one of these as
well that's right
link in the description to sign up for a
giveaway where we're giving up away the
exact copy of this and you can customize
your case as well
if the brofist aesthetic is in your
taste I respect it even though you're
100% wrong this model is called the
neuron origin PC is the only custom PC
company to have their own line of
exclusive desktop cases like this neuron
case because these case have magnetic
feet so just like micronus you can lay
it horizontally or vertically so it can
do this and it can do this it has an
Intel Core i $9.99 hundred K eight core
three point six to five gigahertz max
turbo single 11 gigabyte and video
g-force r-tx 28 ID and founders Edition
that's right 64 gigabyte G's skills
Trident Z ddr4 3,000 megahertz four
times sixteen gigabyte I don't know what
any of this means but i 100% need it so
i can record myself watching memes
ordered PC also comes with 24/7 365 days
a year lifetime tech support for free on
all their pcs right now they have Black
Friday sale and Cyber Monday sale where
you can get up to 850 dollars in value
right now they have offers like an
Origin gaming laptop starting at one
thousand two hundred ninety nine dollars
with free ground shipping and much more
check it out
Thank You origin for sponsoring this
video and thank you for this amazing
computer well this is jump into it let's
get on with the video
in my battle against T series two of my
fellow closest YouTube brother
jacksepticeye markiplier and remain
silent
so therefore I have picked two new
frames to help me out
hello welcome that's right I totally
didn't pay you guys welcome PewDiePie
clone and male feminist okay this is
Joel and Dame and we're gonna we're
gonna review some reddit stuff can you
feel the crash look so goddamn short how
in a good state everyone keeps saying
I'm sure it but this is not true yeah if
you want to make Felix feel really
uncomfortable
what should see the shoes Felix why
you're here for ready and nothing else
quit your bull yeah spoilers for viewing
this Lawai subreddit just kidding we're
doing wait your [ __ ] is it Brad
outside of editing this I don't know
okay what they're gonna have to censor
out the word every time we're gonna have
to come up with something other than
there's no L sensory hey look my leaves
look what is it look what it is look
Swedish boys this is very important
quickly [ __ ] for me and for yours well I
assume yeah me too hey Jacksonville we
can't wait to open our doors to you and
your family the American flag is
supposed to be flown higher than any
other country's flag here boy hi our
flags are flown according to the United
States code when flags of two or more
nations are displayed they are to be
flown from separate staffs of the same
height the flag should be approximately
equal size international usage forbids
the display of the flag of one nation
above of another nation in time
peace I have no idea what's that title
for like the United States clearly has a
code that shows the specific height at
which their flag should be shown in
comparison to other flags and IKEA
happen to be able to really off
immediately that's that's pretty
terrible idea I mean I United States
delivering the twist ending John
Carpenter would have been 70 years old
today we celebrate his birthday by
looking back at his five favorite films
two Rotten Tomatoes despite how it
appears I'm actually dead how do you get
that wrong is legendary
did he do Halloween the thing Halloween
yeah yeah right
it's got so many thousand apples we have
to be good it's already works that's
already why I got banned for the movie
sub for comments like 200 up votes so
people liked it and agreed but the mod
banned it because what's a conservative
opinion really to me we don't do other
Texan
movie smart here here's the comment you
were banned for your Islamic which means
you're did please go away
clearly I struck a chord with some
people and you're just hating it had no
you're just a hater is now do exactly as
I say and I'll remove the Hat if you
don't then I'll destroy your phone if
you tried to block or report me I'll
still destroy now send your age and a
life Facebook to prove you're real
what kind of phone in my on what you
have 30 seconds to seven-member I
destroy it you didn't answer it's been
more than 30 student destroy you didn't
really plan this I'm just destroy it do
you think that God I'm still waiting on
that look I'm gonna get go get some
lunch have just got okay sure you done
yet I mean you can't take that long and
I only have like four pictures on my
phone and all of
I want to see the pigeons have you guys
have forgotten anyone like that I don't
think I've had anyone claiming to hack
my phone you'd like it's like it's not
me oversee patrol did your story on your
channel about when you used to steal
[ __ ] you have right next
gotta love people in this town you
haven't talked to them in over ten years
and still they try to tear you down
because you doing better than them not
sure what they get out of it but all you
can do is keep doing what we do making
people happy and time will show what's
the truth appreciate everyone Chris
sticks by us hey remember that time you
call me which is the most offensive the
most you just kind of spread positivity
you try to make it harder for my poor
hard way so when NASA first started
sending astronauts into space they
realized that the ballpoint pen would
not work at zero gravity a million
dollar investment in two years of test
result in a pen that could ride in space
upside down on almost any surface and at
temperatures ranging from below bottle
and when confronted with the same
problem the Russians used a pencil in
the early is a space like those Russians
and Americans use pencils in space and
fortunately pencil that is made of
graphite a highly conductive material
snap reflect light sand particles in
zero-gravity are hugely problematic as
they will get sucked into the air
ventilation or electronic equipment
easily causing shorts or fires and a few
oxygen environment of the capsule after
the phone
this is a radius thing ever I do think
it's interesting though yeah I love when
people just call that kind of thing out
NASA is not that stupid right it's
freaking NASA there's been several
studies that show that nASA has made way
more money than was invested into it
really things that have been invented
from it
baby formula came from NASA what's baby
for babies why are they showing a
computer mice okay
they invented them right what let's do
so NASA make the mouse oh my god the
shoes you're wearing my comfortable
you're comfortable cell phone cameras
okay that's pretty at night I don't know
if I'm thankful for that actually yeah
NASA invented selfies kids say for
highways there's no way NASA did that
right we're both oh we got a nice little
musk one here masculine you can play
Gill on musk okay thank you
Elon Musk gave Kanye West and Kim
Kardashian a custom silver Tesla Wow
this is false nose complex what are you
doing you guys think he'll and must just
goes on Twitter every half hour and
searches his own named clear I am a
married man and my wife has stopped all
interest in sex instead she has now
become my hookup manager who who manages
my Facebook and Twitter page and gives
me advice on how to get sex dates and
get laid a stadium may ask me anything
this is Rory's mom I'm sorry but he is
not a married man just a 16 year old boy
with a vivid imagination also please
stop with the private messages
especially the explicit ones whoa
it's 10:35 p.m. and I had to use all my
self-control to not burst I reading this
I almost busted a long thank you for
this entertainment what a savage mom
Rory's mom like imagine being called out
like that yeah see reckon II just did
that intentionally to make it a meme of
himself how would a mom like see that
immediately
and then like yeah I don't see see ya
create your balls put your book careful
who you call ugly in middle school no
one called you ugly we went to the same
school just post your pic and go yes
yeah that's something that really
bothers me the whole I need an excuse to
post this selfie that makes me seem like
I am a victim
do you guys remember when selfies were
frowned upon do you remember when
uploading videos was Friday bomb like oh
that was weird
friends like that was like when I think
you and I started yeah I was like and
now like I see all my friends like I'm
talking like all this [ __ ] like Facebook
and Instagram and stuff what everyone is
doing it yeah we've fought through the
stick here we asked to empowered Swedish
boys I was actually working at the World
Trade Center but my daughter's fifth
birthday have been to be on September
11th so I decided to stay home that day
if she was born a few hours later I
might not be here today that's crazy
dumb you're not still here oh do you
glad you're still glad you're still here
Opie this is a third comment to give me
chills hmm well let's see if he explains
his post history saying he is 19 year
old male in Maryland yeah why is
favorite childhood video games on a
mobile device holy [ __ ] you weren't
kidding that's F up dude what is with so
many people in the thread lying by these
stories so I'm glad you and the others
are coming max disgust yeah come peace
okay this is a review from crepes and
cone
okay what kind of voice do you think
this would be like the voice of someone
ordering them all ordered what order to
work for to find a fingernail and a hair
in my food absolutely shocking I was
told I would have to wait another hour
to get a fresh one I asked for a refund
but never received one wouldn't send my
worst enemy here anyways this is removed
teacher why would you write that maybe
it's someone who just hates that person
did you guys ever write reviews alright
maybe we can check out so oh yeah yeah
Felix is a guy who actually writes
reviews the thing I don't know why you
guys think that's so weird
it's hell I don't know anyone else who
writes reviews it's just like doing a
favor you using your own name like it's
really funny Felix Kjellberg it's the
pizza here it's alright they need to
know how can they improve this place
looks like it's about to fall apart and
I don't think anyone would mind if it
did what made you so angry at this place
that that was your they were actually
lovely in there I almost really liked
but the staff was good you reviewed
Nando's don't know what Nando's is they
need my review business Nando's needs
the endorsement of PewDiePie to get by
hey another waffle one we have waffles
too but we've also got pie does Waffle
House have pie I didn't think so yes we
have
oh my god let's go back oh okay
hope you enjoyed this reddit video check
out Joel and Dave's channel link in
description
they make videos once every wow it's big
like full bugs my video out today oh
yeah check out the daily video it's been
2 months today and that's it goodbye
[Music]
Dave
[Applause]